if it seems like the US is constantly
about to hit the debt limit also known
as the debt ceiling it's because it is
it's kind of like the horror film that
Hollywood keeps making sequels of even
though no one liked the first one every
few years or sometimes months Congress
needs to vote to raise it and they will
need to do it again sometime in 2023
when Congress will look like this a
republican held house and a democratic
held Senate with a democrat in the White
House and Republicans plan on using the
debt ceiling as leverage to negotiate
spending cuts the debt ceiling needs to
be lifted but wouldn't it be a normal
thing if we're 31 trillion dollars in
debt not to just give a blank check so
while Congress still looks like this
Democrats are looking to act on the debt
ceiling so it's not something
Republicans can use next year here are
three things they might do in that lame
duck session
but first a brief history lesson from
what happened another time Congress
looked like this the debt limit was
raised many times through recent history
without much debate until 2011 when
Republicans decided to use it as a
bargaining chip to negotiate for more
spending cuts the American people will
not accept an increase in the debt limit
without significant spending cuts and
reforms the three sides debated as the
U.S got closer and closer to defaulting
until Congressional leaders reached a
deal with the president just one day
before Uncle Sam hit his credit limit
the U.S didn't default but the country's
perfect AAA rating was downgraded by s p
in part because of the fight where no
longer the gold standard as it relates
to the world's economy longer term we
may see a rise in borrowing costs if
history repeats itself that is a scary
scenario for this government the U.S
can't default on its debt that would
have huge implications for the economy
worldwide even just getting close to the
debt limit can cause big problems for
the economy So to avoid a fight next
year Democrats this year have three
options
first is to just get rid of the debt
limit altogether the US is one of two
countries that even have one in the
first place and there's already
legislation introduced to make it like
all these other countries so the
treasury could just take on as much debt
as it needs to pay for spending that
Congress already voted for
treasury secretary Janet Yellen was
asked last year if she'd support the
repeal yes I would I believe it's very
destructive to put the president and
myself the treasury secretary in the
situation where we might be unable to
pay the bills that result from those
past decisions but Biden says he
wouldn't sign it I mean just say we
don't have a debt limit
no so that's the least likely
possibility the second is to just raise
the debt limit so high it's not really a
problem that's what the other country
with the debt limit Denmark does its
debt would have to quadruple to reach
its current limit the likely plan
wouldn't be to raise the US's that high
but just enough to remove it as
something that would need to be debated
in 2023 it's not due till next year but
the Democrats could pass something
potentially with Republican votes also
in the Senate that would raise it so we
didn't have to worry about it say till
2024 2025.
but the most likely plan is to
restructure the way the debt ceiling is
raised in the first place and make it
not congress's problem the idea
originates from that 2011 battle it was
an idea that was brought forward by now
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell
who at the time was looking for ways to
help his members avoid having to vote
for the debt ceiling but give them way
to vote against it currently a majority
in the house and the Senate have to vote
for raising the debt ceiling and then it
signed or vetoed by the president like
most bills but members of Congress
especially Republicans don't like having
to vote for raising the debt ceiling so
what several bipartisan plans would do
is essentially reverse this it would
give the executive branch so the
president or even the treasury secretary
the authority to raise the debt limit
and Congress could pass a joint
resolution of disapproval basically
Congress instead of voting to
affirmatively raise the debt ceiling
members of Congress could vote basically
against raising the debt ceiling but to
act actually override the executive
branch they would need a two-thirds
majority vote
however not everyone wants to take the
debate away from Congress simply because
it's crisises that make Congress
actually get things done we find
ourselves at the edge of cliffs a lot
and Congress and that seems to be some
of the one of the only motivators to get
people to make concessions and and reach
agreements but on the debt ceiling that
is a very high risk strategy many
Republicans want that high-risk strategy
to get spending cuts in other measures
they worry they won't get under a
Democratic president Republicans have
tried to work with reach across the
aisle and have been shut out of many of
those conversations if we could do that
then we wouldn't need to uh you know
threaten you know use the threat of the
debt ceiling as a negotiating tool there
are definitely divisions within the
Republican Party about how they see that
some of them really want it want to go
to the brink and you know Force these
changes that they really believe are
important and others don't think we
should be using the debt ceiling that
way and would rather just take care of
it maybe even would rather Democrats
take care of it in the lame duck before
they have to worry about it next year in
their majority so Democrats have about
two months to decide on one of these
paths and potentially gain Republican
support for it
otherwise come 2023 we'll likely see an
epic debt limit debate again